- Mesdames et messieurs,
bonsoir. Je vous annonce
qu'à partir de maintenant,
vous serez en direct
de l'univers.
- France Beaudoin, on s'est
parlé 20 minutes avant cette
entrevue, et là, tout de suite,
ça a été : "Il faut que tu me
tutoie." J'ai l'impression
qu'on se connaît depuis
les 10 dernières années.
(rires)
C'est un peu ça,
France Beaudoin. C'ennn
contact immédiat. Je m'intéresse
à toi. Comment se sont passées
tes vacances?
FRANCE BEAUDOIN
animatrice et ucucuctrice
- C'est... Si tu me dis "vous",
premièrement, je vais regarder
à qui tu parles en arrière.
Mais non, c'est... Pourquoi,
pooioioi perdre le temps?
Pourquoi pas se brancher
direct sur... pourquoi pas
laisser les convenances,
pourquoi pas? Il y a
e e e politesse, évidemment,
mais il y a 3-4 couches
qu'on peut enlever, des fois.
- Direct sur l'émotion.
- Bien, direct sur la personne,
sur ce que tu as le goût de
dire. J'irai pas te gratter
le bobo, c'est pas ça.
Mais... je trouve que
des fois, on perd du temps à...
Puis moi, je prends pour acquis
que si tu me poses une question
que je n'ai pas le goût
d'y répondre, je vaiste le dire.
Playlist d'entraînement,
aussi, dans la cave
chez vous, à suer en masse.
- Mais c'est pas ça,
tes émissions? C'est
très frontal. "En direct de
ununununivers", c'est... t'sais,
"Pour emporter", pas de temps,
là, on va carrément dans
le coeur. On vise le coeur
de l'invité, mais aussi,
du téléspectateur, puis ça,
ça se sent tout de suite.
- Bien, c'est-à-dire qu'on vise,
on essaie de l'authenticité
puis ce qui est vrai.
Dans "En direct", par exemple,
c'est important pour nous,
quand même, de faire attention
aux gens parce qu'on sait
que quand ils vont être
assis sur cette chaise-là,
avec la vulnéré,é,é,é, avec
le direct, avec l'émotion
des gens qui attendent pas,
avec... t'sais, perdre
le contrôle, déjà, juste
de pas savoir pour bien
des gens, c'esàààà énorme.
Alors, ce qu'on leur dit,
c'est : "On reste dans votre
questionnaire, on vous promet
qu'on va pas sortir de là."
C'est bien en masse.
S'il y a des choses qui
sont trop, trop, trop émotives
sur papier, on ne va pas aller
là non plus parce qu'on sait
que ça va prendre 10 couches
de plus, rendu en ondes.
- Je veux une confidence.
La personnalité qui a été
le plus émotive, où il a fallu
lui faire de la gestion?
- Un qui a était très,
très émotif, c'est
Jean-Philippe Wauthier,
qui a fini en foetus.
- En foetus?
- Bien, on l'avait kidnappé.
À sa défense, il savait
pas qui qui s'en venait.
Alors ça, j'avoue que...
j'avoue qu'on l'attendait pas.
En fait, quand il s'est mis
à pleurer sur la chanson de...
son cousin, je pense, en fait,
qui faisait juste jouer
de la guitare sur une chanson
heavy métal dans le numéro
d'ouverture, on s'est dit :
OK, là, on vécécécécécéchapper.
S'il se met à pleurer là,
on est finis.
- On vient de l'échapper.
- On est finis!- On est finis.
(rires)
- Tu t'es appelé, cet automne,
Capitaine Rebondissement.
- Dans un balado avec
Jay Du Temple, vous
que "En direct de l'univers" est
né, en fait, dans votre famille,
des amoureux de musique,
où un soir, vous avez décidé
rererererere plaisir à votre mè.
- Oui.
- ... en invitant un de ses
artistes préférés à la maisEt l.
- Ah! Ça a levé solide!
♪ Les gens des États
se souviendront pour longtemps ♪
♪ Il y avait au Canada ♪
- Je te dirais que là où j'ai
pas tant de mérite, c'est que
chez nous, ce qu
à "En direct de l'univers",
c'est comme une production
professionnelle de ce qui
se fait dans notre maison,
chez nous, depuis toujours.
Dans la famille de ma mère,
tout le monde joue de la musique
et c'était les beaux-frères qui
surprenaient les belles-soeurs.
On partait dans des pa
le coffre plein de déguisements,
de trucs cachés, de monde
qui sortait de partout.
Et un soir, effectivement,
on avait fait venir Jeanne-d'Arc
Charlebois pour ma mère,
qu'elle aimait beaucoup.
Elle est arrivée avec la...
celle qui avait été pianiste
de Miles Davis à l'époque.
Ça cogne à la porte,
ma mère a son accordéon.
Qu'est-ce que c'est ça?
On est... je sais pas,
peut-être une cinquantaine
dans la cuisine, chez nous,
dans le salon, et Jeanne-d'Arc
Charlebois et sa pianiste
se mettent à
l'histoire du Québec.
Parce que c'était ça,
leurs chansons, c'était
l'histoire du Québec.
Et là, on e        à écouter.
Effectivement, il y avait
quelque chose qui fonctionnait.
Mais ça, c'est il y a
très, très, très longtemps.
- Et il s'en passe des choses
avec les Grands Ballets,
ces jours-ci.
- Parmi toutes les émissions
que tu produis, il y en a
une toute nouvelle à l'a
ça s'appelle "Retour vers
la culture". Émission culturelle
un peu comme l'émission "Arrêt
culturel", qui est diffusée
à RDI. Alors, la question...
- Que j'adore!
- OK!
(rires)
Alors, la question qui tue...
- Oui.
- Qu'est-ce qui fait une bonne
émission culturelle en 2021?
- Bien... ce sera pas à moi
de dire si c'est bon ou pas,
mais je te dirais que ce que
nous, on souhaitait faire,
en tout cas, parce que
tant mieux s'il y en a de
toutes sortes, nous, on voulait
donner le goût de la culture.
Parce qu'on a fait d
autour de nous puis des sondages
un petit peu plus officiels
aussi, qui nous disaient
que les gens, par moments,
se sentent pas concernés parrtrt
honte de dire qu'ils ont pas lu
ce livre-là, qu'ils connaissent
pas cet artiste-là, v v v v v v.
Les gens nous répondaient
vraiment ça. Puis, même
quand on a commencé à faire
"Pour emporter", l'é
où on parle des mots, donc
de littérature, mais des mots
en général, il y a des artistes
très, très connus qui t t t t t:
"J'ai pas... j'ai pas la culture
assez élaborée en littérature
pour y aller". Je disais :
bien voyons donc! On parle
des mots, rsrsrsrsrsrsrsrsrsrs,
cette espèce de complexe-là
pour bien des gens, ce qu'on
comprenait dans nos sondages,
onononononononononon voulait ta.
Juste dire : voici ce qui
est disponible. Essaie.
- France Beaudoin, ça a été
un véritable cadeau.
Merci beaucoup.
- Partagé. Merci